[Music]  gosh Rich there's so much more that we  could talk about and we haven't even  touched on the topic of how you can heal  your gut without even lifting a fork we  did a exercise intervention  and it was literally 15 minutes of  exercise that's it  and we did not change people's diets in  doing the 15-minute exercise  intervention we saw a shift in their gut  microbiome and the results was that we  had more butyrate producing microbes now  of course like we want to strive to do  even more than that if we can I mean we  know that people who get more sleep more  restful sleep have more diversity within  their gut microbiome the people that we  surround ourselves with  very interesting study Rich where they  looked at spouses the people who felt  closest to their spouse were sharing the  most microbes the people who felt most  distant from their spouse were not so  we're making substitutions that are  leveling up our gut microbiome leveling  up our health